there is no perfect partner well there's
also no perfect career I resent the
passion thing sets too high of a bar and
so I think it's really about like lots
of action and then all of a sudden you
get good at whatever the thing is and
then you like it and then you find your
passion you didn't find your passion you
created it it sounds the same thing with
like romantic partners for a lot of
younger people there's so many fish in
the sea there's so many swipe rights
that you're looking for this perfect key
or this perfect lock and it's just not
like that everything has elements that
you don't want and I think the
expectation that everything is going to
work out makes it so that nothing does
for most people